[Music]
okay everybody i'm
really really really really excited
today because i
am joined by karen fukuhara aka
kimiko aka the female
karen how are you hi steve how are you
i'm good thanks for having me karen i
think i'm in the boat of just a bunch of
fans right now are
are just in shock and disbelief at the
ending of episode 3 with stormfront
and i i think we all kind of just want
to know right now at this moment like
is camiko ready to go kill stormfront oh
oh my goodness yes after what happens in
episode three i think stormfront
is due for a beating if not
a brutal murder by the hands of kimiko
yeah and like i feel like kimiko is the
perfect person to have
now as like that having her arch nemesis
because
we see kimiko even in episode 2 just rip
that guy's head off it's something she
does with ease
and before we jump all into that
speaking of episode 2 i kind of want to
just talk about
how we see here that we get introduced
now to kumiko's brother
mouse and there's this conflict they
have
that he still kind of believes in the
shining light
and kamiko really knows the truth about
them so it puts camiko in this weird
spot of
do i help have my brother be kidnapped
or do i let him go
can you kind of delve us into her
thought process in that kind of
part of the storyline yeah um i think
you know
when she when she's reunited with
kenji it was something that she didn't
believe
could happen you know she thought he
could be dead
she thought she would never be able to
see him again and so
having this opportunity it's just a
dream come true for her
and so you we can see that sort of
connection between the two in episode
two
and it's quickly shattered by the fact
that he
has a different agenda and you know it's
hard for her because
she just wants to continue the rather
sister relationship that
they had going on from before but it's
not possible
and i think this is another example of
how
her life her family's life has been
affected for the worse by
shining light first of all and also
va international um and that is a
realization that she has you know not
only were they kidnapped and
forced into the life but also
they have altered his mind they have
gone so far that he is thinking in
this you know [ __ ] up way that she'll
never get him back
she'll never get this kind-hearted
brother back and so that's very sad for
her
so you feel like she kind of feels like
she's lost him in a way already
yeah there's a realization that she has
you know when
they're talking in the middle of the
street and she's saying
why are you saying this what you know
she's very confused and
caught off guard because that's not the
kenji that she knows
and partly she moves with him but she's
trying her hardest not to because she
wants to hold on to him
what's left of him and there's not a
single thing in the world she wouldn't
do
to convince him otherwise yeah and
that's
totally interesting what you're saying
there and i think it lends into how
even more interesting the story with
kimiko and kenji gets in episode three
because
we learned that they made their own
language
through all everything they went through
growing up so i have to ask you as an
actress how did you guys go about this
what's really going on with the type of
sign language you're doing how does that
even come about
yeah i'm so excited to read the script
and
see that she has another mode of
communication you know
and the language she speaks in season
two
the sign language is not actually afl
it's a completely
made-up language by my coach amanda
rischer
who was the coach for sally
hawkins in shape of water oh wow
very exciting to me yeah it's so cool
and
amanda has hearing aids but she's signed
her whole life
and therefore she's an expert in her
field and
she created this beautiful language for
kenji and kumiko
and i mean that's a hard thing to do
creating a language
so um and you know what i loved about
her
was that she would create
these gestures that sort of had
a little bit to do with our language so
for example
the word boy in kimiko's language is
someone throwing a pitch or throwing a
baseball
or kimiko's nickname for kenji is mouth
and two hands coming together so it kind
of looks like a small animal
is feeding off of someone's hand and
that was mouth and so she created
meaning behind these movements
and that helped me in the beginning it
helped me trigger my memory
and to learn the actual language but you
know in the long run it just
when i was doing it on the day it
really just meant so much more because
there was significant meaning and a
connection and a tie
to what i was saying yeah and it's
so impressive i mean when i'm watching
it i'm like how the hell are they doing
this and
it's interesting because you have so
much experience in different
forms of acting and people knowing you
also from she-ra and doing
voice acting comparing to here where
it's mostly
literally face and body acting can you
kind of
maybe try to hint at what you find more
challenging oh
um you know i think the
sign language was definitely challenging
because it's something that i
had never done before you know i've
spoken my entire life
so uh grammar glimmer kind of comes
naturally to me
um and it's a lot of fun playing
a character like that she's a princess a
warrior
she's a fighter she's courageous and
she's not
you know unapologetic so it's really fun
playing
her and it comes naturally but
for kimiko it's everything is new
and so i'm learning as i go and i think
that it's more challenging
yeah for sure yeah well that that's
what's so impressive about it is it
doesn't show that you're
learning as you go it seems like you've
been doing this forever and
thank you no and i think it's it's
really just made
kimiko so much more interesting this
season and it seems like there's a lot
of focus on kimiko and
that all these characters and the boys
are getting a little more meat to each
of their stories
and i'm just shocked because i i have to
now jump into episode three because i'm
still
trying to take in what just happened but
i i really love how
when kenji throws all the blocks into
homelander and then
tries to run away again but kamiko runs
after him and they get this
nice moment of i love you and it goes
back to what they're saying about
protecting each other
and then we get stormfront saying hey
guys and the rest is history so
i have to ask when you had this scene
with stormfront coming in and first
attacking you guys
i know you have a history of karate i i
think you have a brown belt if i'm
correct
i do yeah see so do you do any of your
own stunts in general in the show
you know i always have to give credit to
my stunt double and my stunt coordinator
keith bong
stunt coordinator and irma leon who has
was also my stunt double for suicide
squad and
she's amazing at what she does and
i will never be on her level right but
you know
it's it's fun because i do get to do a
lot of the safer stunts um
if there's not a lot of risk involved i
i get to throw a couple punches and
that day with aya was so fun because we
were both on wires because we are
actually on top of that tall building
and she you know she has to choke me out
um and my head is kind of falling off
the ledge
and so i we had to be on wires the
riggers were there
so i mean i have fun with it it's just
another experience that you wouldn't
normally
be able to have and after the
exhilarating feeling
right after you finish a stunt is
what i live for it's just so fun to do
and
you feel like you've done it you know
you faced your fears
i have a fear of hype yeah i have a fear
of heights too yeah
yeah but you could do it too if you know
that you're going to be
okay you can do it you know it's it's
the most fearful when like
you're responsible for your own life and
you're just kind of like walking on a
ledge and if you trip
you fall and die but um you're in good
hands
in the hands of a professional so no i
love that that's really cool and i
i just wonder too because i said this in
my review of episode three but
it blew me away the way you sold the
emotion of kamiko here
on her face when she sees what's
happened to her brother by storm front
can you just as an actress talk about
getting into a mindset for a scene like
that and making sure like
okay am i selling this as good as i can
on the face like how do you even get
there it's such an emotional scene
yeah i think i think a lot of people
can a lot of actors are able to watch
themselves
and then give themselves feedback but i
have never really been
able to do that it i can do that for you
know action scenes and i can do that for
um less emotional scenes but i kind of
get in that in my head
when i have to do a deeper dive and um
so i try not to watch myself for those i
think you know preparation
is key it's you know a lot of exploring
past experiences and pulling as much
into the performance out of yourself
i've never
experienced such a tragic loss and so i
have to
do a little bit of imagination work and
yeah
it's definitely fulfilling
after all of those are done but for me
it's um
it's you know it's it's it's a dark
dark time yeah i mean fun thinking about
all those things
no and it it's it's really just maybe
the darkest the show has gone yet
and i i think too with the episode just
ending with kamiko just
with this death stare at stormfront on
the tv can you
kind of give us a little hint into where
her head is at now
and maybe does she feel a little
responsible for what happened to her
brother in a way
oh absolutely absolutely so well said
because
you know in that final moment in episode
three we see her determination
and her determination for vengeance
she is in a very very very dark place
and she's ready to maul
storms in any way possible and
that becomes her life mission i think up
till
up till he dies she has this sense
and she has this mission to save
and look out for her little brother and
before she
she thought she completely lost all of
her family members she'd never get them
back
and then she was given this opportunity
to meet him and meet with him again and
she realizes that he he's still alive
and she can still protect him and
that gives her the will to live and
she kind of feels like she owes it to
her
parents i have to do this this is my
life mission
to protect my brother and then that is
taken away
brutally by stormfront in episode three
and so
her entire perspective
on the world changes and
she is motivated by by vengeance and
wanting to get revenge for the rest of
the season
everybody you heard it from karen
herself here you can't get a better
explanation of camiko's thought process
right there and behind the scenes stuff
it's so exciting it's
really cool karen because to me that
scene at the end of episode three was
just on the same level of something i'll
never forget just like it was with negan
his entrance and the walking dead it's
that same just
crazy brutalness and it i i absolutely
[ __ ] loved it and
your performance just makes it that much
better so everyone
please make sure to watch the boys
season two episodes one through three
are out now and every friday there'll be
a new episode
on amazon prime karen is there anything
else you would want to promote before i
let you go
uh no i think that's it uh season two
all right karen thanks so much for
talking to me and i hope you have a
great rest of your day
yay that was so fun thank you